okay so uh yes first let me thank the
organizer for inviting me to this uh
very nice conference
uh
so
as i understand the
topic of my talk is a bit different from
most of the talks here and
the reason being that not many talks are
concerning non-equilibrium
so this will be about non-equilibrium
properties but i will strictly keep the
one-dimensional system so
it will be about non-equilibrium
it will be about open systems
and driven
and
quantum chains
so it will be 1d
so i make a short menu for
for what i'm going to speak about today
uh essentially
i mean okay i put this title
working rough states just kind of to
provoke the attention but essentially
i'm speaking about three types of exact
solutions which i can put under common
frame
and the common frame is is this
concept of a walking rap state which
i'll try to introduce but essentially i
do it on the case of of several examples
and so there are three cases
exactly solvable cases
case one
will be the very
famous
uh spin one half xxz chain
so the anisotropic heisenberg model
about which we know very much but
still i claim that there are some
interesting things to be learned when
you drive the system out of equilibrium
the second model is the fermi hubbard
model so fermi hubbard
chain
and the third model
is a very recent work which has been
just published in nuclear physics b
uh is the lysoderm spin one chain
spin one
chain
so before i forget let me just give you
a few references on this i mean maybe i
will not be able to cover everything but
this is sort of this is the main course
and these two things are desserts which
i'm not think i mean i might not be able
to get there but you will somehow i hope
you get the idea when i just got the xx
case but i just want to claim from the
beginning that there is a common frame
under which you can put also these two
other models even though much less is
understood about the structure of the
solution here so the only thing which is
common is this structure of the of the
graph state
of the of the walking craft state so
let me just give you
briefly the ref the main references
so this is prl
six
and then there is harvard this url this
year
112
0 3 0 6
0 3
and this is nuclear physics b
8 8 2
4
5. okay so let's start with case one
okay let me just start with the with a
picture a scheme of of the setup so what
i'm going to consider is a quantum chain
so it's a it's it's not a tensor network
yet but i'll come to and try to connect
to the topic of the workshop so
there'll be a little bit of tensor
networks not much i mean everything is
more or less mps
uh
but just to you know to somehow make
some advertisements why this should be
still of some interest this mps will
have infinite one dimension so
uh and uh just to try to make some some
some pre-interpretation of what i'm
going to say i mean the graph comes from
trying to get the connectivity in this
infinite dimensional
angular space
so but
let me just go
slowly into this so let's just take a
quantum chain which is a chain of
quantum particles be it uh spins one
half fermions
uh so finite level quantum systems you
can think of quantum spin systems
and uh then you couple it to some
uh
to some uh
external reservoirs yeah so the idea is
to have an open quantum system
but uh
there is also uh i mean you may think of
okay i mean why you know this is a
dissipative quantum system this is a
driven driven dissipative quantum system
but the way i want to couple it to the
outside world is is really as benign as
i can think of so i don't want to
destroy the coherent character of the
many body dynamics here i mean at least
i don't want to
i i
i i try to affect it as little as
possible so i just couple it to the
outside world locally so i will take
let's say limb that operators which will
be acting after locally on the degrees
of freedom at the boundaries of the
system
so let me just you know just immediately
start to
discuss
case one which is the xxz chain you know
very well so i'll just you know repeat
the hamiltonian
so
the
i will denote the system size by little
n
and this will be the generator of the
unitary dynamics in the bulk of the
system
and then i will produce
uh um
jump operators which affect as i say
only local degrees of freedom near the
boundaries of the chain
which will try to
uh uh which will produce incoherent
processes right these are this is this
is the coherent part and the incoherent
part is generated by four
uh limb blot operators
which in this xx case could be simply
simply for example sigma plus
sigma minus at the left end
or
sigma plus
and sigma minus at the right end
and uh these
constants a b c and d are positive
linear numbers
which can be interpreted as parades
so now this is where the classic that
the quantum world means classical world
i mean this is a hybrid system
it is uh i mean it is a hamiltonian a
coherent dynamics in the bug and there
is a kind of a
constant monitoring of the system by the
environment locally at the boundaries
okay then you can okay i don't want to
enter into the discussion of how one
derives this dynamics of course you know
i mean i guess in this uh still this
type of community i don't have to
discuss
introducing the liblat equation although
i could i mean if there is maybe i don't
know but but still i mean let me just
straight
uh go straight to the to the to the
evolution equation so what i'm going to
consider is the evolution equation for
the density matrix
which is as i say two parts it is the
unitary part
plus the dissipator
i will write super operators with the
heads so this is a you know a machine
which linear machine which takes the
matrix and spits out an operator this is
not a derivative of density matrix
so
so this is uh
simply
and this is the anti-commentator yeah so
this is the limblot equation
take limb blood
dynamics
this is a markovian uh master equation
which describes the evolution of the
system so now
you may wonder whether you know taking a
system for which you know that there is
a
big bulk of literature about uh
equilibrium ground state uh suspect from
thermodynamics and so on
uh which is covered essentially by
techniques which are known as quantum
inverse scattering and algebraic data
so if you take such a model and you
couple it to the outside world by some
uh incoherent processes then you may
wonder whether there exists exact
solutions for the steady state
and whether these exact solutions tell
you something new about the
dynamics of the model
i try to argue that
you know both answers to both of these
questions are positive so and try to be
as you know as precise as i can be in
such a lecture
uh
for the first part then the desserts i
will give you just briefly i guess
because one hour is not enough but
anyway let me just
so what i'm going to do is i consider a
non-equilibrium steady state
which is defined as
a limit
sorry i will write it as
rho infinity
which is the limit to infinity of this
dynamics here is a fixed point
sorry
it's a fixed point so this is clearly
the the the fixed point of the ruby
operator
so this guy satisfies the steady state
limelight equation which is
commutator with the hamiltonian should
be equal to the dissipator on this
operator
so this is the equation of motion
for the steady state
which we are trying to solve
okay so
and now
uh
okay now i'll try to you know just i'll
have to probably buy some of the of the
of the statements i'm going to make but
still i'll try to connect to the i mean
even though this is not the way this has
been derived i mean this has been
derived in a bit of school way but what
has been the progress of the last let's
say last last year was that we were able
to mainly in the i forgot to mention the
quarters but these papers have been done
but
two of them have done in collaboration
with my
graduate student ileoski
so what we have realized with levski was
that actually this has been i mean that
this exact solution can be put under the
frame
of uh young baxter equations and uh i
think we will learn more about uh
algebraic beta and that's with
professors correct stock tomorrow but
still i try to you know i try to write
to a lax matrix which you will be able
to connect to the standard lux matrix of
algebraic data answers okay so let me
just you know tell you to prove okay
yes before that so just going back to
the physics part
are you this for instance the two first
another preserved particle number right
is that um
are we assuming something about the ray
i mean is there a particle
is there a fixed particle
that's a good point yes there should be
a conserved quantity in this case this
case is a monetization in this case a
particle number in this case also
i mean in this case also there is a
constant quantity i mean i mean the way
i produce the noise
coming to the environment is that i will
conserve a number of particles of one
species there are three species there's
been one half model this is pin one well
there are three species of particles
it's a three-color model and i will
conserve let's say red color
and the reservoirs will produce
incoherent
change of blue to green and green to
blue so there will be always a conserved
quantity
in the hamiltonian part and the action
of the linblad
operators will be to change this
conserved quantity from
let's say by plus one or minus one
so yeah that's a good thing to do
right the open system does not preserve
it but about preserve it so it's it's it
makes sense to study you know but that's
a very good question you ask because
that's exactly the idea why i mean this
is a physical motivation why you want to
study this model is because you want to
study states with currents
because these are states which produce
currents and these are these are this is
paradigm of non-equilibrium physics all
right to to to to to to understand
an only problem states with currents
yeah
and then you know you may want to
connect this to leave what linear
response teaches you or you want to go
far away from your response both both
connections can be made
but that's probably going beyond this
talk but you know it's very good thanks
for the question yeah because it
definitely is a part of motivation for
why one one needs to why one should be
interested to study this
okay
so let me just yeah so two things two
two sort of
remarkable properties of these steady
state density matrix can be made which
are universal which which essentially
are through uh true for all three models
the first so there are the observations
uh
the raw infinity that is steady state as
the operator can be factorized
into
a square root
into non-hermitian square root
which is i would call it an s operator
and i will put explicitly the dependence
on the system size so s of n will be
an operator which lives in two to the n
by two to the n uh dimensional keyboard
space in physical hilbert space and the
density matrix will be written as such
of course this is nothing i mean you say
okay or any there's positive operators
in the written in this form but there'll
be more to it i mean this this will be
what i claim what is known in algebra
cholesky decomposition
or ski decomposition meaning that this
guy s is an upper triangular matrix in a
computational basis
this comes
from particular property of the
representation of su-2 i mean there is
there is a su-2 group behind and there
is the the that
there are non-unitary representations of
as you do which one has to consider and
the fact that i have to use highest
weight representations of su-2
immediately applies that implies as you
will see i mean i try to to be uh
i'll try to stress this point again but
i mean this is kind of
important i mean at least it seems
important for me at the moment because
i can only understand fully the
structure of solution for this model for
these two models
the structure is not completely
understood i mean there is no
corresponding young baxter equation yet
there is two models
as you know for example for the harvard
model there is this rasterization but
it's not really uh it doesn't really
have the the the universality of the
of the of the su-2 our metrics so
uh
so it's a bit i mean there are things to
be discussed and
yeah but anyway let me just go straight
to the to the to this solution so the
first this is the first observation the
first observation there is a kulesky
factorization
and then the the rest is you know this
is like
there's the matrix i mean this is again
a naive that's in naive pedestrians
interpretation of what we are doing i
mean this is density matrix the sd
matrix is about probabilities but in
quantum quantum mechanics we work with
probability amplitudes so first we
factorize density matrix you know to
have an object which describes
probability amplitudes and then we shall
we shall discuss what this object does
and then this object
sn admits a nice matrix product
representation
so there is an mpo and that's for
for the for the square root of density
matrix
so there are some indices
s1 to sn
you start from a state which i call zero
now you are in antillas space so these
are until operators
this is not a trace you see this is not
a trace but you start from some left
state and then you
take a product of matrices you end up in
the right state
and then you have a
tensor product of pauli matrices
yeah
okay so this is an anzac yeah you know
that always you can write such answers
and for exponentially large and still
space you can always write any state as
an npo
now the question is what is the property
of these guys here
these matrices first remarkable
observation is that
this indices only run
over poly matrices
plus minus and zero so i take a complete
basis of poly matrices sigma plus sigma
minus sigma z and sigma zero
now this guy is forbidden
this guy doesn't enter into the unsets
so how come
well i mean
first
i mean this was sort of the uh
the idea of how one derives and how how
one derives this solution but
as i say now it sounds a bit obscure uh
having this connection to the lux
mattresses of of of of of of
uh
of the integrability
so it's better maybe to explain this in
terms of the lux matrix
so
uh
yeah uh but anyway before going into
that let me just sketch i mean that how
does this imply that there is a
tensor network behind the density matrix
yeah i mean this uh you know this uh
s operator
i will write as a
as an mps yeah i mean it's an mpo
so this uh double index uh double line i
will use to denote an infinite
dimensional bond space so as i say i
mean the representation space or the the
the ancillary space it should be
infinitely dimensional as we become
clear you know in a minute
so and then you start from at stage four
zero which is you can call a ground
state or a highest weight state and uh
then it's this is the s yeah so this is
a
a a and so on
and then this is one s
then you have to multiply that as dagger
and as the agaris a similar beast
but
you know you do
and you contract of course this is
multiplication of operators
so this is the brav the first the cat of
the second to bravo the second ticket of
the the second and so on so you contract
along this
uh and here you have to put the
the the
if you want the adjoint
matrices a bar
the complex conjugate matrices a bar
so if you want at the end of the day we
will have this tensor leather
structure of the non-equipment steady
state
but i claim i mean you can learn
everything about the system by just
looking at one one leg of this of this
ladder
so and then
how does one
prove or construct such a solution
uh
sort of
the proof or better to say the
construction of this matrices a follows
from these observations
namely it's sort of easy to observe that
uh these answers
solves the
the the the fixed point condition for
the niblat equation if and only if
the square root that is the sn has the
following property
you see i mean this is kind of funny
uh equation right
it tells you that the commentator of the
hamiltonian with this operator has to be
something which is connected to this
operator for a system of size n minus
one attaching some trivial operator
which in this case is sigma z which has
to do with the number of particles
namely this is the say one excitation at
the left or at the right
yeah and this epsilon okay i forgot to
say what is epsilon
uh
there is something which i forgot to say
namely i consider now a special case of
driving where i put
a driving parameter a to epsilon i put b
to zero i put c to zero and i put the d
to epsilon
which means i have the strongest
possible driving where i only inject
spin up excitations on the left
and i only let's say
inject spin down excitations on the
right or i only flip up spins on the
left and only flip down excitations on
the right
with some rates which are for
convenience equal they don't have to be
equal i mean there could be asymmetric
rates one can still write exact solution
but the simplest let's say the most
symmetric exact solution happens if the
rates are equal
so this epsilon is a parameter is the
one of the main parameters in the game
which is the strength of coupling to the
environment
z is the okay so this is in physical
space so this operator is 2 to the n by
2 this is up this is 2 to the n minus 1
times 2 to the n minus 1 so this is 2 by
2.
so this is a spin space spin one half
space
one specifically decide this is first
episode this is the rest this is this is
the last side
okay so this is i mean the first point
to understand this
solution is to to understand that the
lymphatic equation is equivalent to this
equation
for the steady state yeah
and then the second step is to see that
this follows immediately from
a solution of young babster equation
for the
so-called lux matrix
which is the solution
of young buckster equation
in
a representation
in a pro in representation which is a
product of fundamental representation in
an arbitrary spin and this spin
can be any complex number
so
there is this
lux matrix
which is you can be written as a two by
two matrix
which you can write uh for example from
professor corey's book
it is
but you know but one thing you have to
be careful
there's one crucial modification from
what is written in standard textbooks in
in in in in
in uh
algebraic onsets for the equilibrium
systems
namely you have to allow
this uh
auxiliary degree of freedom to be
arbitrary spin
so this matrix is now
uh you know these metrics have two has
two legs in one leg it is uh it belongs
to a
a spin one half and in the second leg it
belongs to the element so this is two by
two metrics this is a physical space to
wait a matrix and its elements are
infinity dimensional matrices which are
connected to these operators s plus s
minus and sz
phi is the spectral parameter yes
and gamma is
related to anisotropy
which is
cosine gamma
i use more or less standard notation but
phi is the spectral parameter yes which
i will use to manipulate the solution
okay so now what is these guys here
these are the these are okay there is a
parameter a little s yeah this is a as i
say this is this is little s i'm sorry
for my ugly writing but little s as i
say is a free complex parameter i i
should not fix it anymore i should not
fix it yet so
so there are three operators
which are
the
generators of the so-called quantum
group
uq sl2
and can be represented for any s
and you may you may
this q could be related again to
parameter gamma q is eye to the eye
gamma so this is this trigonometric
deformation if you want
and then these operators as z are three
diagonal matrices
so there is an ancillary space which is
infinitely dimensional
i will write them in this trigonometric
way
so in terms of trigonometric functions
of
of the parameters of the model
and then there is s minus
and then see
there is this spin parameter coming into
into two parts of the
of the guys
so these are three three diagonal
operators these are angular momentum
essentially this is deformed angular
momentum
and there is a special state which you
call highest weight state
which which is this uh zero state which
has this property that you know if you
try to raise the spin you cannot do it
it manipulates it's initiated
and uh if you take the projection of the
spin on this state you get this little s
times this state
so little s could be considered as
angular momentum
and then if you
apply s minus
you get a series which never terminates
in principle so you have an infinity
dimensional representation of
essentially this is su 2 if q is equal
to 1 but it's also deformed as u2 so
it's the quantum symmetry of the xxd
chain
okay uh but yeah so but the point is now
here it's kind of this is an unitary
representation i mean this is you know
there are unit representations and
people have mostly used
in i would say my interpretation of the
of the of of of the business in
equilibrium physics people would most
mostly use
unitary representations but here it's
necessary to use non-integral non-unity
representations of this of of this big
group of the quantum quantum group which
is the symmetry of the model
and okay so how how does then this uh
this
mpo happen i mean maybe this will be
connected to what as i say that
professor griffin has to say tomorrow
because this will be again generating
generating metrics product states from
from uh from
solutions of young baxter's equations
but you know in this case the only
difference will be that this this
matrices will have infinite bond
dimension because this this has to do
with this infinite imaginarity of this
obvious
of this until space
okay so let me just conclude this
connection so now the statement is which
is very easy to prove
uh the statement is the following
and i'm introducing the lux matrix we
realize the following that this square
root of the density matrix
can be written as the highest weight
expectation value or if you want a
ground set excitation value
of
this guy where you put a representation
from a spectral parameter to pi over 2
s
and then you take tensor product in spin
space i mean by this index s i mean i
take tensor product in spin space
because this matrix has two spaces there
is a spin space two by two
uh two dimensional spin space and
infinite inversion of ancillary space
you take tensor product
in spin space
uh and of course this is a normal
product in ancilla space so it's like
yeah and then you take a expectation of
that
and uh
yeah and to see that i mean that's sort
of okay and then yeah and
there is a connection i mean to see that
this solves now this the claim is this
solves this defining equation for the
square root
which uh
uh
where is it it's here
so this solves this equation
if
there is a connection between
the dissipation parameter or the
coupling to the environment
and the spin representation parameter
so you see there is an eye here so which
means that
that spin representation parameter has
to be completely imaginary
so
and it's connected to the to the noise
strand
so
yeah so the idea is that okay noise now
affects the you know the
uh i mean noise i mean the strength of
the noise or the stance of the coupling
or the strength of the driving
uh tells you what representation of the
what not what non-unit representation of
the uq su-2 you should use to produce
the mpo for the steady state
and to see that i mean this is really
kind of obvious
i mean this you know the fact that we
solve this equation simply follows from
the local essentially from the young
baxter equation
written on the
product space fundamental
times fundamental
times this complex pin
if you write local form of this young
master equation and if you derive with
respect to the spectral parameter then
you get simply the hamiltonian i mean
the hamiltonian density
if i call this a hamiltonian density
it's a two body operator
then this is this hamiltonian
commutator with l
this is tensor product in spin space
across l is simply two times sine
gamma
l cross
this is derivative with respect to
with respect to spectral parameter
so this is
this is simply the young boxer equation
but you see this is also a kind of
operator divergence condition this is
the time derivative of the sort of a
two-sided operator which is given in
terms of some sort of divergence yeah so
if you simply turn the product this you
make a tensor product of this guy from
the left and from the right by
appropriate powers you know and then sum
up
uh and take the sandwich between zero
zero then you exactly get this kind of
state
and this tells you that you know on the
left hand side you will get on the left
hand side
this on the right hand side will get
with this
for this particular choice of epsilon
so this is the i mean the way you can
now show that this is exactly the
solution now okay
this was a bit
but how am i doing the time okay so
that's okay so this was a bit maybe
technical but let me try to conclude let
me try to give you a pictorial
interpretation of what we have done
uh so let me now i mean let me go to
this concept which i uh advocated in the
title the the concept of a graph so i
mean this representation space is a bit
you know it's a it's quite trivial but
still not completely so let's try to
describe what this matrix product is
doing because these are infinity
dimensional matrices we can describe
this in terms of simple objects so
infinite infinite dimension matrices but
they are acting as three diagonal
operators
so which means that these three diagonal
operators now which enter and let me
just now to write out these operators
and this operator simply can be written
out from here putting spectral parameter
to be pi over 2
you get a 0 simply to be a cosine of
diagonal matrix which is again a
diagonal matrix
which i can write
so as a sum k bigger larger from zero
some amplitude which i will denote as
k k
okay okay
this will be just the definition of
these amplitudes i mean you can really
read them out from this representation
of the equivalence u2
and then there is a plus
which is essentially sine gamma times s
plus
at s
this you can use to define the
amplitudes a going from k to k plus one
you see now you have sort of a graph
of
states now this is in ancilla space so i
will draw them vertically
so this is the
state number zero state number one state
number two
and so on
this is the highest weight state i
i wrote it as a lowest state but anyway
and then
there there will be some transitions as
you see i mean these are like kind of
leather operators
i mean this is all kind of trivial but
this is just that you know for hybrid
model becomes less trivial so it's nice
to introduce the language when it's
trivial
okay so i forgot to complete this is the
transition from state k to k plus one
and please i mean
you should interrupt me if there is
anything unclear
everything is completely clear i guess
okay
okay so i simply introduce these these
amplitudes which are simply given in
terms of these trigonometric functions
times you know where this s is given in
terms of the noise parameter so
everything is explicit now this is
really you can do this in mathematica
you can compute as you like i mean this
is not nothing is hidden anywhere
okay so
and now okay so what and then i
introduce this amplitude yeah and these
amplitudes i will you know i touch this
amplitude so this is a this is a graph
yeah graph is now
so i introduce a graph now which is the
set of
edges and vertices
and these vertices are
0 1 2 and so on and edges
are
pairs of neighboring vertices which is 0
0
1 1
and so on so they are diagonal and then
there is okay
and there is k k plus 1 which are and
then k plus 1 k
so there are three types of edges
there is diagonal edge
there is this self connection
then there is a raising edge
and then there is lowering edge
yeah
and to each edge i associate an
amplitude
and then i will write
okay uh
i think i will
start erasing stuff
so then the square root of the density
matrix i can now
write in terms of a sum
which goes over
all blocks of this graph which start at
the origin the origin being the highest
weight state or the this this end point
of the same infinite graph and in n
steps arrive back to the origin
so let me denote this
set of edges
e1
e2 to en
being a member of the set of all walks
which at n steps so this w script w will
be the set of all walks
which
starting at this uh node end up in this
this
the other the other node in exactly in
steps
and so these are just
a e a 1
a e 2
2 a e n
ok this is the amplitude and then there
is the operator in physical space
and the operator can be given in terms
of a tensor product
of some operators in simple spin space
which are attached to each
which are attached to each edge
so
that means that i will attach it so i
will denote i will define something
which i call an index function
omega which associates to each edge
an
element
in the
matrix space of two by two matrices so
it is a local local physical operator
namely
omega of diagonal edges will be sigma
zero
omega of kk plus 1 edges that is raising
edges will be sigma plus and omega of k
minus 1 will be sigma minus
so this will be a plus
and this would be a minus
yeah
and now i have simple selection rules of
which terms can exist here or which
terms cannot exist
namely i always have to start with a
plus
which means that i always have to have a
plus to the left sigma plus to the left
of sigma minus
which is the koleski property which
means that
you know that you cannot have anything
with
because this is exactly the matrix
element of the
of the of the of the main body operator
s
and yeah so all these selection rules
which comes from the structure of the
graph tells you the structure of this
matrix
so first of all it's upper triangular
second of all all diagonal elements are
identical
which means that this matrix is
completely i mean the spectrum of this
matrix is completely boring it has just
one value but it's jordan's structure is
not trivial
but it's singular values of course are
connected to the eigenvalues of a row by
the way this also implies that the
the density matrix of the steady state
is full rank because the all eigenvalues
of the all diagonal
i mean this anyway the the square root
so
you know this is not the
object that i have in mind this object
the square root of density operator i
mean is a full rank operator so the
density operator itself is the rank
operator
i'm sorry for a bit of school notation i
mean
you should keep in mind that different
different indices mean different
symbols
okay so is it clear i mean
there's some question
yeah so that should be clear i guess i
mean this is just uh
everything should be explicit yeah this
is a
entirely explicit
solution for non-equilibrium
right
so have you
compared it to what people can
in other contexts by using
yes yes
i'll
so there are a couple of issues so let
me try to tell you about the spinoff
project
which has to do with relating this to
what people have observed in looking at
molecular dynamics of the xxz chain
so okay i mean you may wonder okay i
mean there's one thing which you can do
directly i mean you can solve uh
limit equations of this sort i mean once
you solve the system exactly you don't
have to solve it numerically but you can
compare with numerical solutions and you
will find nice agreement but this is not
what you want because you know
i mean you may wonder whether this very
naive and very simplistic uh
type of quantum quantum master equation
has anything to do with reality
so uh and then it turns out that anyway
this is kind of
this is kind of interesting and uh
for example
why is it interesting because this gives
us
a new set of concepts of motion i mean
we have learned you know you give us
talk today i mean we have learned about
uh how how important are concepts of
motion local concepts of local integrals
of motion local conserved operators now
this model has been i mean you know it
appears or it appears three years ago
this model has been beaten to death i
mean everybody saw that i mean any and
probably every expert so that he
understood everything about concept of
motion of this model
and then you know the
claim i would like to make that maybe
this is not totally true that there are
concepts of motion which are not exactly
local but they are what i would call a
pseudo-local or quasi-local still i'm
not kind of
frustrated between the
use of these two objectives i'm sorry
but because they are not
well i mean okay but i don't want to go
this discussion now but anyway they are
for all practical purposes local enough
i mean practical meaning that you can
you can estimate important transport
coefficients of
of linear response uh properties of the
model like through the weights which uh
describe let's say
uh dc conductivity divergence of this
conductivity of this model
so i mean in this critical strip i mean
there is maybe i should tell just
briefly what is the
what is the the idea there i mean in the
for delta less than one that is for
gamma being real
uh
there has been mounting uh numerical
evidence that
the spin conductivity the spin current
that is the spin conductivity
at high temperature diverges for this
model that is there is a finite uh
finite through the weight which is
related to the to the
to the conductivity by
you know there is a there could be in
principle a peak at omega equal to zero
this peak has a weight which is called
through the weight
and then there is the rest which is
called the rectorized conductivity
so this is a real part of the
conductivity this is a regularized
connectivity so there was a lot of
discussion in condensed metal community
about this through the weight and
there's been a lot of numerics and there
were there were different
kind of claims that either this guy goes
to zero or if it stays finite namely
there was there was inequalities people
used in terms of conserved quantities
and these inequalities were exhausting
all conserved quantities and still the
lower bound on this guy was zero which
means that
if there's nothing else than this then
the best claim would be that this
through the weights should eventually go
to zero even though this was not shown
by numerical experiments using quite
sophisticated techniques like the mrg
so now i just want to you know spend
five minutes on showing how the solution
of this very abstract lymphatic driven
model tells you something new about it
so the the point is that you can produce
new concept
produce
new
conserved
from the
quasi-local
charges
what does it mean
okay i have to be brief and only very
sketchy about it
but uh i mean the key point in this
model is there is a particle hold
symmetry or
uh in the spin language it should be
called a spin flip symmetry so there is
an operator let me call it p
which is the product of sigma x at all
sides
which is a spin flip of each spin at
each physical site right
and now this guy commute with the
hamiltonian
it also commutes with all known
conserved quantities let's call them q
sub j
because all these conserved quantities
come from a transfer matrix of uh
you know algebraic with ads technology
and this transfer matrix let's call it
little tau
which is a function still of some
spectral parameter
is essentially written in terms of the
same lux matrix
okay now i'm calling specter per meter
lambda but never mind maybe i can call
it phi still
and then this spin number spin should be
one half so you should consider
fundamental representation if you
consider fundamental representation of
course then fundamental position is two
by two then you take
you take a tensor product to power n
so you take a monotony and then you take
a trace
trace of another mean this is the
transfer matrix and then you take a
logarithmic derivative of the transfer
matrix at a particular point you can
show these are local operators and
that's it but the problem is that these
guys all commute
with this parity operator this spin flip
operator so anything you derive from
them also commutes with operator the
problem is that the current
anti-commutes
so
if you take a spin current so let me
just define a spin car and briefly
so in this language
so if you take this guy
then you apply you know
product with this product of sigma x you
find that it is minus this guy times
this
so anything you do at infinite
temperature
has zero overlap i mean
with the spin current so everything
which is related to the transfer matrix
of the fundamental representation of
beta assets is has zero property has
zero overlapping with the spin current
so what you have to do and this now this
approach shows you what to do and still
of course at the end of the day you want
to have something which is
quite local yeah quite local meaning
that
it's enough local meaning that you can
define some norm of the operator which
is extensive quantity
that's enough
okay so
just
um
so let me define now something which you
know you could
consider as a non-hermitian transfer
matrix
so using this
spin a complex spin representation
you can define
this guy but this guy lives in an
infinite dimension of single space so
you should not use the trace because
trace would not exist so it should use
highest weight representation and you
should use highest weight state
now this guy is not does not exactly
commute with the hamiltonian first of
all it commutes with itself so you can
show that
these guys form
a commuting set of
quantities i mean this is a continuous
family continuing family depending
continuously on two parameters s and
five both complex
these guys are committing about
themselves but they are not quite
commuting with the hamiltonian that's
the problem
because you know you don't have the
trace here so there is a problem with
the boundary anyway hamiltonian is an
open cyst it's an open heism it's an
open chain it's not periodic chain so
you have to worry about what happens in
the boundary
so and then the magic happens but if you
define the following operator
which i call z sub n but but yeah but
what's nice about this guy is that you
know it does not commute with the parity
operator but if you if you apply this
parity operator from the left it is the
same as if you apply it from the right
and transpose this operator t
so this guy is not
self self joint neither symmetric matrix
in physical space
you know it is not hermitian you know
that's the you know when you go to
non-equilibrium you should worry about
you know everything we start becoming
not your mission
and every representations of groups
should be non-unit i mean
need not to be united anymore so you
should consider knowing the
representations
and this is what you get
yeah so you have this p
p which produces
that this w this w transpose
and so since w and w transports are two
independent operators and they also
commute this guy commutes with w
transpose you can form out of ww
transpose let's say anti-commission
anti-hermitian
uh
combination and you call this okay this
depends on several parameters so i will
just define what i mean
so
so i mean that's that just the
the the crooks of the tricks is here so
i just want to and then finish because i
mean i will finish with this and
go to the dessert but just you know i
try to just be a little bit
explicit on this
so
the claim is
okay this guy is non-local
but
the magic happens when you take a
complex pin parameter to zero
when you this is a complex pin parameter
so you can put it to zero zero there is
a scalar scalar is boring but you expand
your transfer matrix your generalized
non-contribution transfer matrix around
as equal to zero and take the first term
the first term
happens to be
quasi local operator in the sense that
so this guy doesn't depend on spin sorry
this just depends on one
continuous parameter
so okay just take it equal guy so this
is just that
this is just the
sorbinus norm if you want
this operator
and this is something which goes like
over n of n
and that's enough for you then you can
use this so-called mazur bounce to bound
through the weight and you find
actually what's nice is that you find if
you explore really the full set of these
guys and there is a there's a set which
is simply a stripping complex plane for
which these guys exist and they are
quasi loco so i
i don't want to go into that but
i mean there is there is a kind of nice
set and then you can solve you know
you can you know you can optimize the
bounds within all these guys in the set
it amounts to solve some platform
integral equations and then you end up
with the result which is equivalent to
one of the better results which was
obtained by first by zotos and then by
klumper
uh
at particular values of gamma which is
pi over m
so it agrees with beta answers
but at this particular this particular
value of points but this this result
applies to any commensurate value of the
isotropy so it goes beyond that
okay that's sort of
yeah i think i still have a couple of
minutes maybe 10 minutes or so so
what does it mean
right this is what this is what i would
define as quasi local
so you have an operator
whose frobenius norm goes
is extensive so this operator is a sum
of
of local fuzzy local guys of guys which
are localized not on finite support but
they can be written as sums of
of operators on large and larger support
with smaller and smaller norm
but at the end of the day you should
worry only about this extensive prop
excessivity property
so these are translation variant sums
essentially i mean okay i i didn't say
anything about what happens at the
boundary
there are terms at the boundary which
remain
uh which are only local that's again the
point they are only local city only
locate the boundaries so when you do
then you have to use some developments
on boundaries to show that they are
benign when you address the let's say
the kubo formula
but uh this is really convenient and
what is the importance of this having
these
conserved quantities
yeah right they can be used to
rigorously bound the
let's say the the weight some transport
ballistic transport coefficient from
below
and there was no i know the other ones
don't work because only others don't
work because of the symmetry because of
the
positive parity symmetry and these guys
have negative particles the same as the
current
and this is not special to the x and z
model i mean there are many models for
which the same harvard model has the
same property so i have no time now to
go into hubbard model i've just sketched
it very briefly i just want to i'll just
try to
draw a walking graph state for the
hubble model because it's kind of sexy
but i then i will conclude
so
is there any other question maybe before
urgently on the xxc
sorry so is the bone you find for the
judy wave is the function of temperature
or is that just no this is the actually
this is the infinite temperature this is
the living order of infinite expansion
but you can get it
it could be possible to apply this for
finer temperature but then i'm not
i don't know how to do anything exactly
so then you should maybe use again some
dmrg you know to take this as an input
and then
do some dmrg to estimate this this
because then you have to do this
kubomori uh products uh
with these guys so at some point at the
beta and then
i don't know i mean
it should be worth life to do but you
know it's beyond what can be done by
cancer paper and mathematica
there is i mean this is this
here beta is equal to zero right i mean
beta is going to zero
from above so this is leading order in
expansion and high temperature expansion
so there is no temperature here i mean
this is the infinite temperature
i mean this this connects to infinite
temperature linear response
and finite energy would be more
difficult as i just explained
okay so let me just
go in five minutes to
the first dessert and then
ah sorry i mean i there's a whole thing
i have to skip so
i mean that now i can make sort of a
poll i mean either i say something about
computing observables because i didn't
say anything about continuous or i go to
the harvard model
i don't know it's
there
dessert okay so i skip computing
observers but anyway should be obvious
for anyone who
we've seen i mean there was this
there was this stanza leather uh uh
so anyway forget about observables i
mean it's straightforward to compute
yeah one can compute currents and and
magnetization profiles
uh
one
okay just forget so let's go to harvard
so
okay i need i try to be very brief so
let me just i mean you take this
rather standard spin
leather formulation of the harvard model
so two spins of electrons represent as
two species of spins
sigma and tau spins
ignition conjugate
plus
here i will call the interaction as
little u over four
i mean doesn't really matter because i
will not show you any explicit results
for the amplitudes which you can easily
find in the paper
let's just
so this is a harvard model i mean it's
like a spin ladder
now i produce uh four
uh linda channels for the left boundary
uh i will not discriminate uh spin up
and spin down electron so this will be
like a charge driving
from the left i will inject electrons of
both pins
from the right i will take them out
sigma n minus tau n minus
and again
magically it happens that
this factorization works
which where again this sn is a cholesky
factor so there is an you know again it
solves a kind of defining relation which
i will not even
attempt to write out but let me just
write you know the the the walking graph
representation of sn
so there is a graph
which i
will maybe draw on this board
which is now a planner graph
but not quite planar i mean it's a quasi
quasi-linear graph but it can be nice
nicely written in a plane
which you can
think of
by
connect concatenating
squares
and you denote uh
you denote
notes of the graph as diagonal notes
this one equals zero and this is the
highest weight note
then these guys one two three four and
so on
and then you have this off diagonal
notes
which the ones to the
uh left diagonal i will call one half
minus because one half because it's
between zero and one
three half minus
five half minus
seven half minus
and then those guys on oh on the other
side of the diagonal we call one half
plus
three half plus
five half plus
seven half plus yeah
and so on and so forth
and then there are connections and then
i will just make
out of you know
i mean to be able to be able to more
compactly express was what this index
function does i will color some notes i
will take these notes every other set
knows i will take them as black
so there will be black and white notes
and on diagonal these notes will be
black white
and then there are transitions and that
there are transitions on the edges of
the square and on the diagonals
so all these lines this is directed
graph but i will not draw the arrows so
all all the each pair of nodes which are
connected are connected in both ways and
then there are also diagonal self
connections
and these diagonal nodes have self
multiplicity too
so there are two operators associated to
the self connection here
so i mean just there is a graph
which is the set of
edges and nodes which are just
vertices which i just plotted
and furthermore
in principle it's possible and now the
idea is just you know there is a matrix
product operator for the s operator
which you know i will not even write out
but the matrix s i mean the the defining
matrix is a i have infinitely bonded
they have infinite one dimension
so uh the question is how to organize
this the structure of this underlying
space
and
the
uh
and this can be so the unt last space
let's get let's say is a direct sum of
local spaces
which
which belong to
vertices of the graph
and these local spaces
for
for the half integer vertices for of
diagonal vertices k minus one half
plus minus
are simply scalars
and the hilbert spaces for diagonal
vertices
are two dimensional
so in principle there could be more than
one dimensional local space but it's
finite dimensional so then we have
amplitudes but these amplitudes are you
know when they go from scalar to color
they are complex numbers but they go
from scalar to spin or they are they are
two vectors they are rows or columns
yeah
but anyway so there i assign for for
each pair for each edge which is
which is a pair of notes i assign an
amplitude
a e which i will not write out i mean
you can imagine it's not it's it's it's
it's it's
they look quite simple i mean they are
linear functions of epsilon there are
linear functions of k and then there are
some sign factors some some stuff but
they are kind of kind of simple yeah and
then
at the end of the day you simply write a
tensor pro i mean
this guy again very easily
so this is a vector of edges this is a
walk
so the square root of density matrix is
again a sum of all walks
starting from node 0 of this graph
and then
then this index function can be
understood
so this is this index function it can be
understood quite
quite nicely from the diagram of the
graph
essentially
this b
uh is sort of a component of the
connection if connection is vertical
then only b2 which is the vertical
component is plus if it goes up it's
minus if it goes down
and if it's either 0 or z
if it stays the same
and then the color of the node
determines whether it's 0 or z whether
when you connect black nodes it's z when
you connect white nodes is 0. so it's a
nice i mean it's a clear coding
okay now
of course there is a question how you
know
how this coding connects to some young
boxster structure and that's completely
open
so uh for this i would like to conclude
and thank you for your attention
questions
can you understand right that if you do
the finite lattice the dimension is not
infinity you can just cut it at n
right these ladder operators right so
right it scales linearly right right
right right so if there would be some
entropy this would scale as log n yeah
because the bond dimension is i mean if
you define some sort of operator entropy
for this object
okay so
the schmitt rank
is n is n over two
i mean here for the hubbard is two times
n because you know the package of four
states for each side
that is boxes
now if you allow me just a minute i mean
the second dessert which i had to skip
is much more interesting because there
the entire space is is generated by
three degrees of freedom this you could
think of as quasi one degree of freedom
right this is like uh you know it's like
quasi-1d graph so it's one degree of
freedom behind it's like a one bosom
plus some spin
in this direction but for a light other
length model you have actually two
bosons and a complex pin there is a
three degree of three infinity degrees
of freedom
so the the the graph is essentially part
of three-dimensional lattice and the
full through lattice so there's no
which can be again written explicitly
and uh and what effect does it have
only on this operator
right it's effects effects just after
the point that we are not unable to
compute observables by not knowing
anything more about the solution so
uh i mean then you can plug the solution
to the computer and you can go to n
equal to 10 because this thing's
exploding it goes to i mean it's
polynomial complexity but it goes to end
and power six i mean the transfer matrix
because the you know there are three
degrees of freedom per side
so uh for the s operator though you go
like n cube but for the transfer matrix
you have to double it so you go like and
enter the power six and you are dead
after n equal to ten so you have to have
an extra insight to computer servers
there and and and so so that means
actually that your with your information
is bonded by something like lock
lock of m
the mutual information in your fixed
point is that something that is generic
for all these new equilibrium processes
it's genetic for this i mean i think
it's generic produce exact solutions i
mean for like for the integral i would
call this integral of non-equilibrium
density operators and they are probably
very different than generic than the
operators now if you have a
non-equilibrium system i mean
non-integral systems if you break let's
say if you have a meter in the
hamiltonian but you should break into
the beam
ah it's a good question what happens so
this would be the other
of an area while basically this nice
it's possible i mean
there's still some sort of area i mean
based on what we based on experience we
had with michael villarreach some years
ago we tried the first the emergency
call from this i mean it looks like
there is still some sort of area
but
but it also seems that there are
transitions to cases where there is no
area
any other question
if not um is are we coming by the floor
is that when what we do four o'clock
uh
yes
okay so um
you